i'm single i'm 36 and i am you know i'm
trying to assess these things that's why
i
i offered that up so quickly is because
i do i'm realizing like i
i'm starting to place different value on
things that i need in a relationship for
a man now like i really want a man
who is okay with like he can cry he goes
to therapy
not not uh not cryotherapy just because
you watched one
joe rogan youtube clip where you learned
about a breathing
wim hof breathing doesn't mean you're
ready to be a
like a giving lover and have compassion
um but i want a guy that like works on
himself i go to therapy i
recently stopped because i realized i
was too emotionally advanced for the men
that i was like wanting to
men need to catch up a little bit and
i'm not saying that as a dig men
obviously don't go to therapy as often
as women do because you guys are
you know society tells you that you're
not supposed to feel and men are really
scared to go to therapy that they'll get
in there
and you'll be sitting across from like
an old woman with a phd
who's like listening you're feeling
she's jotting things down and she'll be
like okay i heard everything and she'll
close her book and go
um i have like a diagnosis you're
you're gay and that she'll have to go
and you know what i have to tell
everyone in your life because it's just
my job and that's what i have to do
which is not all your co-workers which
is not a therapist job by the way
it's clear you know nothing about
therapists and now i have to tell
everyone because that's the therapy code
yes that well i they really think that
there's going to be some admission in
that
there that will make them like the
scaredest thing that heterosexual men
fear is like i might be
gay you know it's just a dumb fear
obviously this is a joke but i think
that there is something to that and i'm
just telling you like
men if you go to therapy and you cry and
talk about your feelings you won't
it's not you're not going to be gay
she's not going to like open your eyes
up to your gay
and if you are gay that's great too i
would really appreciate
that and because i don't want to keep
dating you and have you take out
your aggression on my my [ __ ]
um i um
i i really couldn't commit to that joke
i gave off i was like it's too much
conan's kids might be watching no no no
my kids won't see this i'm just now
checking the rafters
the whole cro the whole crew just ran up
into the rafters
everyone was completely everyone was
completely blown away by that
you know it's interesting though like
it's do you
find that the men that you dated in the
past probably needed to go to therapy
they that's always the reason you know
and and it's nothing
like i don't need you to fix yourself
it's not gonna get fixed we're all
just but be working towards it
acknowledge that you're doing
things aren't working for you anymore my
my ex-boyfriend
we broke up i think because of that
mainly and because i couldn't stop
talking about him on podcasts um
but and breached his trust a lot but
also he wasn't going to therapy we
started hanging out again we're friends
again
and the other day he was like oh i got
to go at three because um i got therapy
and i was like
really like i was like oh my god and he
goes oh no physical therapy and i was
like
uh uh okay he was like i go what for
he's like oh my god my shoulder and i
was like
how he's like oh i punched a wall
because i forgot to dvr the good doctor
i'm like oh yeah
don't look into that burst of aggression
that has nothing to do with your anger
towards your father let's just keep
living life the way you've been doing it
again so he wasn't you for a second
though you thought he was going to
therapy and you were
interested so horned up i'm going to
need physical therapy for how quickly i
dropped to my knees and started
buttoning his pants when he told me he
was going to possibly address his
complex emotions god
well you know what you've you've put it
out there that
because there are a lot of people that
would be very interested in dating you
nikki a lot of good people and you've
put it out it's good
you're putting it out there that you
want a guy
who's done some of the work and is open
to being
emotionally available maybe exploring
their stuff
seeing a therapist tying me up
like wait wait
that was part of the therapy um i love
you
you've lost your uh you've lost your
earphones 30 times during this interview
but i had to borrow some from people
because i cannot keep my own and
they are far too big for my time again i
have the very tiniest ear holes oh man
that's the biggest turn-on for me
it's just they're so tight a
q-tip makes me feel no i i don't even
know but i
i that's nobody by the way that's
nobody's turn on i have the tiniest ear
holes
it's not i literally went to the ear
nose and throat doctor because
my voice is just like i i sound pretty
rough i just got
i'll say that i went to the ear nose and
throat doctor my doctor was like
very hot and i didn't see it coming and
i would have like prepared because
whenever i'm
around a hot guy i make sure all my
holes are like in working order not
those because i was like at the ear does
he put in a thing and i have like
too much wax i don't know why i'm just
like a waxy gal
and he looked inside he goes whoa you do
you
ever use a cute whenever i stick a q-tip
in it literally looks like i stuck it in
a baked ziti like it's i i just make
it was so embarrassing i was like do you
want to check any of the others they're
good
yeah um no yeah i'm looking for a guy um
and i'm working on myself
and i honestly i wanted to like put a
call out there on
your show so anyone watching you're a
fan of conan
i'm a single lady here's what i'm
looking for someone who's emotionally
uh uh involved someone who's uh
doesn't have to be funnier than me just
has to get my jokes if you like conan
you're gonna get my jokes um and then
also looks wise i can be a little
shallow i don't mind height i'm height
blind i don't care i like a short guy
because if you go for a short guy you
can tend to get hotter guys if they're
shorter like on discount
it's like it's like you know getting
like a
designer sweater at marshall's like it's
like overlooked by most people
so like you can get hotter in the face
if you you can get a 10 in the face if
you go five seven in the height
is what i found but so height doesn't
matter but like i like how
women always tend to describe men's like
physical traits that they like
based on like athletes so if i was
building my perfect man it'd be like a
like swimmer's shoulders like runners
legs and like a
golfer's [ __ ] um i don't know what
that means that was just a dumb joke
what is that laugh i don't i don't
i didn't know i just wanted to be able
to hold uh
these earbuds in place i wanted to be
the same
size as mine what am i talking about
oh my mom and dad are watching oh please
you can call you can always call them
and say
um the conan interview got cancelled
don't watch
that's true but they love you too much
and they also
they they hit your parents they came by
the show they came by my parents
are the reason i'm cool they're much
cooler than i am and my dad took me
aside when i was in
i think seventh grade and was like there
is a show that i just
came across it last night it was your
fifth anniversary special
and he he taped he he taped it uh
on vhs and i watched it and i just
you know told you this before but i just
it was this moment for me where i was
like
something out there you felt this way
comedically about people
it's i'm i'm understood the things i've
been laughing about in one lap at
are being done and this is just i
watched your 10th anniversary special
last night oddly enough
and was just reliving some of the
greatest moments
and uh yeah i'm just so grateful you're
still around and will continue to be
around and like
i just that's really i mean calling you
my friend is one of the greatest gifts
of my life well
uh you will see the same thing which is
when you put this stuff out there
it's only because i've been doing it for
a long time but when you put stuff out
there
you're going to meet so many young
people men
and women who come up to you and you're
not even aware you're just doing your
thing right now and then they're going
to come up to you later on and
say when i was seven when i was 10 when
i was 15
i got in trouble because i watched you
and it really like connected with me
so you have no idea how many friends
you're making right now
i mean you hear it all the time from
people but yeah it just goes and
to me that's the nicest thing about
being in this business absolutely that
you know the money's not bad but that's
the best part